[MUSIC PLAYING]
BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
SUSANNAH RAUB: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
RETO MEIER: This is where
the magic happens.
JENNY MURPHY: This is primarily
a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Hello everyone.
My name is Jarek Wilkiewicz.
Welcome to you YouTube
Developers Live.
We have an exciting show
for you today.
In the studio with us
is Greg Schechter.
How are you doing, Greg?
GREG SCHECHTER: I'm
doing very well.
How are you doing?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
I'm doing good.
Greg is our HTML5 developer at
YouTube, and he will talk
about, not surprisingly,
HTML5 at YouTube.
We have Jeremy Walker.
JEREMY WALKER: Hello.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: How are
you doing, Jeremy?
JEREMY WALKER: Pretty good.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: How's life?
JEREMY WALKER: Good.
I got a full night of
sleep last night.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
Congratulations.
We're going to have to keep
you down in your seat.
All that energy level, I think
it's coming through.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah, my four
month finally slept through
the night, so--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Wow,
that's a milestone.
JEREMY WALKER: I'm
pretty stoked.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And
then live from New
York, Jeffrey Posnick.
What up, Jeff?
JEFFREY POSNICK:
How's it going?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Good.
How are you doing?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Pretty good.
Haven't quite fought off my cold
yet, but I'll do my best
to keep the coughing to
a minimum as always.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Still
summer in New York,
or is it fall yet?
JEFFREY POSNICK: It's actually a
lovely period before it gets
too cold, and not quite
as hot as it has been.
So very, very nice.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
Later on in the show, Jeff is
going to discuss our upcoming
migration tool, Stack
Overflow.
We are not going anywhere, but
the way you will get your
support questions answered
is going to change.
And Jeff has worked on that over
the last couple of weeks.
He will give us an update of
what's happening there.
But first, let's turn it over to
Greg, and talk a little bit
about his experience at
YouTube and HTML5.
So first question is, how long
have you been at YouTube, and
what do you do there?
GREG SCHECHTER: So I've been at
YouTube for about two and a
half years now.
And I like to call myself the
web warrior at YouTube.
And specifically, I spend most
of my time working on the
HTML5 player and other
HTML5 related
things around the site.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So what do
you like about working on
YouTube and working
on HTML5 player?
GREG SCHECHTER: So YouTube
is pretty amazing.
And a lot of it is just because
it's such a-- there's
so many awesome cat videos that
I get to watch at work.
But I get to work on bleeding
edge technologies.
This stuff is all changing
every day.
I'm working with a lot of the
browser vendors to really
change the web.
And not only just for people
who are watching videos.
But some of the things that
I work on do help HTML5 in
general, and moving the web
forward, making new APIs.
And this is very exciting
for me and it's a lot
of fun to work on.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So as
a web warrior, who
do you get to fight?
GREG SCHECHTER: Most the time,
my battle is against those
flash developers.
I'm sorry if there's any out
there in the audience.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: We kept
them out today.
GREG SCHECHTER: OK, good.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I think we
have to do that in the
following session.
GREG SCHECHTER: So at YouTube,
one of the big battles with
our player is, do we serve HTML5
or do we serve Flash.
And Flash is this experienced
player.
And HTML5 is the
new young guy.
It's sort of a David and
Goliath situation.
Although I think Flash isn't
really Goliath anymore.
But that's the main battle,
is kicking those
Flash player guys--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I bet
that gets pretty
tiring after a while.
Does it?
GREG SCHECHTER: Sometimes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So what do you
do in your free time when
you need to recharge?
GREG SCHECHTER: In my free
time, I actually--
I do a lot of nature things.
I do a lot of bird watching.
I find weird salamanders and
stuff all over the place.
I take a lot of pictures
and stuff.
I actually have some of my
photography to share.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Oh, great,
yeah, let's look at that.
I think we're sharing them
here in the studio.
GREG SCHECHTER: So let's see.
The first one we have
here, this is one
of my favorite pictures.
It's a green-eyed tree
frog and it's
eating a Huntsman spider.
And I love how the little legs
are sticking out of its mouth.
I was really happy
with that shot.
One of the other ones I have
that is also pretty cool is a
nudibranch.
And this one is just a really
weird creature.
And I found this Australia.
But I love this picture so much
that it's the background
on my Android phone.
And so the next picture I have
is, this is more my bird
watching thing.
And wanted to have some that
were local to the Bay Area,
since that's where I live.
And so this one I thought
was great.
This is a white-throated sparrow
that I found near
Santa Cruz.
And it's just in the
reeds there.
It's just really pretty.
And I really like how the
colors came out with the
yellow in its eyes.
So the next picture, this
one was really cool.
This was a little bit further
south, in Morro Bay.
But I've got a horned
grebe eating a fish.
And it was this nice
action shot.
And I had a bunch of shots
in this series.
And the last one was actually
really close to Mountain View.
This was just in the
Palo Alto Baylands.
And so this is a lovely Anna's
Hummingbird showing off its
nice gorget and the nice pink.
And yeah, so that's
also a great one.
JEFFREY POSNICK: That's
pretty nice.
JEREMY WALKER: That's
really pretty.
Now, to step aside, you've done
Google I/O presentations
the last two years, right?
GREG SCHECHTER: Yeah.
JEREMY WALKER: So what's changed
in web development or
YouTube since your first
presentation to your second
presentation?
GREG SCHECHTER: Sure.
So I think some of the biggest
changes that I've seen are
actually around the
mobile space.
And my talk--
that sort of--
I do HTML5 things.
And the biggest difference
between the first talk that I
gave and the second talk
is the focus on mobile.
And more people are getting
smartphones and tablets.
And it's really becoming
something that web developers
need to think about when they're
building a product.
JEREMY WALKER: So your 2012
was mostly focused on the
mobile side?
GREG SCHECHTER: Yeah.
The talk was HTML5 at YouTube,
stories from the mobile front.
And the idea was basically to
show all the stuff that we're
doing HTML5 related, and talk
about best practices, and how
a lot of those things are really
important to mobile.
And how in the past,
you can't--
you have to use plug-ins--
for example, Flash-- to watch
video, or even Flash to do a
lot of your uploads.
But now with HTML5 being
available, you can make a
richer experience.
And then it's also going to work
on mobile, and with that
being such an emerging place for
development, it's that's
really important that you also
have all that development--
that the time that you put in to
develop also contributes to
your mobile products.
JEREMY WALKER: That's awesome.
I hear there's some things in
the deck quite often, if I'm
not mistaken, that you
enjoy on YouTube.
The feline persuasion.
GREG SCHECHTER: Of course.
I got a lot of--
I'm a big fan of cat videos.
And certainly there's a lot.
In my talk, there's plenty of
cat references, and famous
YouTube references there.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah,
I watched that.
It was pretty funny.
I really enjoyed it.
GREG SCHECHTER: I'm glad
you enjoyed it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And we
will post a link to the
presentation on our stream,
YouTube Developers, in case
you have missed a session
at Google I/O.
Couple of questions about
your session and
mobile web in general.
So I have noticed you have a lot
of web browsers installed
on your phone.
How many?
GREG SCHECHTER: So I think at
the moment there's nine.
And to be fair, some of those
are different versions.
So I have both the Chrome
browser and the Android
browser installed.
I've got Firefox mobile,
Firefox mini, Fire--
sorry, Firefox Mobile, Beta,
Alpha, Aurora, and Opera Mini
and Opera Mobile,
and Opera Next.
And then every now and then,
I'll even end up installing
one of the lesser known ones
like Dolphin, for testing and
making sure things are
working properly.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: You think that
should be the standard
practice for application
developers
targeting mobile web?
Or why do you do that?
Is it just for fun, or are there
any significant feature
differences between
these browsers?
GREG SCHECHTER: It's a little
bit of everything.
So certainly being a web
developer, it's actually quite
common that I never have
just one browser open.
I'm always jumping in and
seeing the new features.
But that's because I enjoy it.
For developers, I think it's
very important to know what
kind of user experience your
users are getting.
And so by me having all these
different browsers on my
phone, I'm able to constantly
look to see what's YouTube
like on Firefox, what's
it like on Chrome,
what's it like on Opera.
And I can understand how these
different browsers work.
And also, for me, I do talk a
lot with the different browser
vendors, and I'll report bugs
back to them so that I can
make sure that YouTube is
working properly for everyone.
And I mean, it's pretty low
cost to install all these
browsers on my phone.
Most of them are in
the app store.
And the ones that aren't, update
really easily if you
just pull them up from
one of the websites.
But yeah, so it's pretty simple,
and it's definitely
something that's helped me get a
better understanding of what
the mobile environment looks
like on all the different
platforms and all the different
ways that users
might be experiencing YouTube.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So there's a
lot of talk about mobile apps,
native apps for mobile.
And the question that I have
in my mind is, in your
opinion, which types
of apps benefit the
most from mobile web?
What are the apps that are
well-suited for mobile
web-based implementation?
GREG SCHECHTER: So I really
think that any app can do well
with HTML5 on mobile.
I think that it's probably most
compelling for a site
that also has a desktop
experience.
Because what you have there is
you have code that you would
share between your desktop
environment and your mobile
environment and maybe even
your-- if for whatever reason,
you're putting it
on a TV as well.
And it's really easy to make
sure that your code works the
same, and you don't have to
rewrite things in a new
language or something.
Everything will convert onto
mobile pretty simply.
Of course, you do have
to make changes.
The interface has
to be different.
Make sure that touch
is working.
But as far as some of the core
structures, like how you would
serve a video or do AJAX
calls and all that,
that's all the same.
That's not going to change if
you're on mobile or if you're
on your desktop.
So that's certainly
something that--
anybody who has to support both,
it's certainly going to
save them a lot of development
time if they don't have to
basically reinvent all their
code in both places.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Which features
do you think are
still missing, and are high
priority, when it comes to
HTML5 support, for mobile
and maybe even
for desktop as well?
GREG SCHECHTER: Sure.
At least for mobile, I spend
most of my time doing video
development.
And I think there's actually
a lot missing there,
specifically on phones.
We have sort of two
main issues.
One is the screen size
is very small.
And so we haven't really been
able to optimize our controls
to deal with when your player
is just very, very tiny, and
it's hard to click on, and you
don't have enough room for
your fingers to interact.
But on top of that, a lot
of times the full screen
experience is out of the
developer's controls and just
goes native playback.
And so all this richness that we
add to our YouTube videos--
whether that be annotations,
or captions,
or even a 3D effect--
we lose that power
and that ability
to make these features.
And so this is, I think,
something that's really
lacking in the mobile
environment, is being able to
have that richness that we saw
on the desktop for video on
mobile as well.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Is this
something that is being
tackled by browser vendors
or standards right now?
GREG SCHECHTER: Absolutely.
Some of it is, and
some of it isn't.
One of the things that
I've actually worked
on recently is WebVTT.
WebVTT is a standard
for captions.
And so with this new HTML5 track
element, we can have
native browser rendering of
our closed captioning.
And so this is great, because
that's one of our features.
That's really important for
people, especially for
accessibility.
I'm often in a crowded place,
and I can't necessarily--
maybe I forgot my headphones.
I can't hear it.
And I would still find
a lot of use for it.
So this will allow us to do--
the browser to do it natively,
and it to work on all these
different mobile places.
I'm excited when that
will finally launch.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So it sounds
like some of the features will
basically move into the browser,
so there's no need
for the developer to implement
it as some sort of an overlay.
GREG SCHECHTER: Certainly
there's a less of a need.
Now, things like annotations at
YouTube, we'll still need
to do that, because that's
specific to us.
But some of the more general
things that we think all video
should have, like closed
captioning, will be integrated
more and more with the browser
as time goes on.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So how happy are you with what
has happened over the last
year, over the last two years,
three years, in this space as
far as the velocity
of that progress?
This kind of goes back to
Jeremy's question about what
has changed between the I/O
2011 presentation that you
gave about our iframe embed and
the iframe API, and the
2012 experience about mobile.
| mean, clearly mobile
is accelerating.
And YouTube, we have recently
announced that we've hit a
billion views per day, which
is a staggering number.
But from a technology
standpoint, a browser support
standpoint, is the progress
fast enough?
Is there things that you think
should be done differently?
And what can the developers
do to help accelerate it?
GREG SCHECHTER: Sure.
So I've got mixed
feelings on it.
Mobile has a lot of issues
at the moment.
And I look at this mostly
with video.
And the differences between--
there's so many differences
between each browser, how they
do different things, what
controls they show.
Can you control the
playback speed?
Does autoplay work?
And there's all these
differences.
And it's really difficult as
a developer to build a rich
experience when I don't
necessarily know how the
browser is going to work.
And the fact that it's
much different
than the desktop space.
And we also see that some of
these mobile browsers aren't
quite on par with the
desktop experience.
For example, it took
us a really long
time to launch Chrome.
The Android browser was
different, it was out of date,
and we didn't have a lot of the
richness that we saw on
the desktop.
Once we got Chrome, that
closed the gap a lot.
But there's still a lot that
needs to be done to match the
richness that we see
on the desktop.
Now on the other hand, I
actually think that Firefox
has been doing a great job.
They've been promoting mobile a
lot with their Boot to Gecko
stuff, and really trying to make
sure that is the central
platform for things.
And in the past year, they've
released a lot of new APIs to
deal with the fact that
the mobile is sort
of a primary device.
And so they've released things
like being able to do
vibration, just with the
JS API, detect ambient
light and all that.
And I think that they're really
moving quickly and
adding that richness to make
it even a richer experience
than you have on a desktop.
So I would like to see some of
the other browsers step up and
do as much as they are.
But of course, it's a lot
of work to get all this
awesomeness into the mobile.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: What's your
development environment like?
What tools do you use for your
hacking and free time, what
frameworks do you like?
Tell us a little bit more
about how you work.
GREG SCHECHTER: Yeah.
So I spend--
I mean I work.
I spend most of my time in
Vim in a simple terminal.
And as far as what frameworks I
use in my free time, I love
JavaScript libraries.
And being a hard core JavaScript
guy, I spend most
of my time working
on the client.
And recently I've been doing a
lot of jQuery, but I'm a die
hard YUI fan when I can.
I used to work at Yahoo in the
past, and I know a lot of the
guys there.
I think that they've built
a really great project.
I'll do either jQuery
or YUI on my own.
Yeah, you know, it's really
pretty simple, just terminal
stuff, nothing too
complicated.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
JEREMY WALKER: Out of curiosity,
do you write your
own code for checking HTML5
stuff, or do you use something
like Modernizr?
GREG SCHECHTER: I often
write my own stuff.
At YouTube, we're always really
concerned about making
sure that our JavaScript is
as minimal as possible.
Depending on the situation, we
might already know ahead of
time that we're going to be in a
HTML5 supported environment,
so we won't necessarily do all
the check-in that Modernizr
does, because we can make it
smaller and just not need all
that extra code.
So we normally do
it on our own.
JEREMY WALKER: So for a third
party developer, would you
suggest they write their own, or
would you suggest they use
something like that?
GREG SCHECHTER: I would suggest
that they use Modernizr.
I don't think they should
necessarily waste their time
writing it themself when
somebody else did it, and did
it well already.
Some of the stuff that we're
doing isn't released yet.
So the stuff I was mentioning
earlier about the track tag,
at the moment you can try that
out, but it's hidden behind a
flag in Chrome, and it's only
in the Opera Next build.
And so the feature detection
there hasn't made it to the
frameworks yet, because
it's not live.
So we have to build these
things, because we're testing
them and helping those browser
vendors move forward with
their things.
But not everybody needs to spend
the time doing that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Another
question that frequently comes
up is, if I use YouTube, when
do I get the HTML5 player?
How can I get the HTML5 player,
and kind of, what is
the logic. how is that
implemented that decides is it
going to be Flash, is it
going to be HTML5?
Can I use HTML5 for
my testing?
Can I force HTML5?
Any hints of how that works and
what the developer should
do if they really want to
experiment with HTML5 support?
GREG SCHECHTER: So my hope is
that we can get all the videos
on HTML5, and that'll be
the default experience.
We're not quite there yet.
Flash has just a couple core
features that we don't yet
have the capabilities to
do in the HTML5 world.
So once that changes, hopefully
we'll be able to get
HTML5 out as the default
experience.
Until then, the easiest way
to get HTML5 is to go to
www.youtube.com/html5, and you
can opt in to the experiment.
And then, assuming that you're
watching a video that supports
all of the--
where our HTML5 player supports
all the features that
we need for that video,
we'll give you HTML5.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Does the opt
in stay with the browser from
which I opted in, or is it
associated with my account?
How does it work?
GREG SCHECHTER: It's cookie
based, so it's going to be
just with that browser,
with that sess--
with that machine.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And will that
apply to embeds as well,
or just for YouTube.com?
GREG SCHECHTER: It will apply
to all YouTube views.
Yeah, so embeds and just
on YouTube.com.
And so if you ever don't
see a video--
if for whatever reason a video
doesn't play, or it plays in
Flash, that's usually because
either the video might have
just some business
logic that--
maybe the stream is secure and
we don't have the ability to
do that yet in HTML5.
So it's things like that, where
it's just features that
we don't yet support.
But you'll still get
the Flash player.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Do you do-- if
I opt in to HTML5, is there
client-side logic that
kicks in, or is this
on the server side?
Like for example, I'm
on a platform that
doesn't support Flash.
Will you actually do that on the
client and figure out that
Flash is not available, or is
this done based on the user
agent header that is
sent by the client,
or how does it work?
GREG SCHECHTER: So we actually
have a bit of both.
The server side sort of
does a basic check.
It guesses what it thinks
your capabilities are.
And that's looking at the user
agent, and so basically if
you're using an old browser,
it's going to assume that you
need Flash.
If you're using a user agent
that we don't know, maybe it's
on a TV or something, we're
going to also assume that it's
Flash, just because
we don't know it.
But then on the clients, we have
a lot of code that says,
all right we're going to try the
Flash Player, that didn't
work at all.
Now we have the ability to
switch over to HTML5.
And once we do that, we actually
essentially opt you
in to using HTML5.
So the second time you
view that page,
you'll get HTML5 again.
We'll remember and we won't keep
trying to give you Flash.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Now in
addition to Flash versus
HTML5, there's always the
issue of codecs, right?
How do you know which codecs
will give platform support?
How you handle that?
GREG SCHECHTER: If you wanted
to check to see what codecs
your browser supports that we
care about at YouTube, once
again, you can go to the
slash HTML5 page.
And you'll see the main formats
that we support are
h.264 and WebM.
And as of today, basically all
videos should you have--
all videos that get watched
should have both formats.
Originally, a year ago, we
didn't quite have all the
videos on WebM, but all
new videos will have
both WebM and h.264.
So we support those
two main ones.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Then in your
code, does the client of
iframe embed actually do any
sort of checking to see which
codecs are supported by
a given browser, or
how does this work?
How is this detected?
GREG SCHECHTER: There's
actually a lot of
logic behind that.
So the HTML5 video tag has
APIs for us to see if it
supports a codec.
So we can see if we have h.264
support or WebM support, and
then we have a list of things.
I'm a big fan of WebM.
I think it's a great format.
So normally, we're going to pick
those formats first and
serve those, unless you're on a
browser that doesn't support
it, and then we'll go h.264.
But on the mobile environment,
it's actually--
today h.264 is a bit
of a better option.
It doesn't consume as much power
because there's chips
built into the phones
that specifically do
the hardware decoding.
And WebM--
there's a couple devices that
have hardware decoding for
WebM, but it's not
that common yet.
So in those situations, if we
know that we're on mobile,
we're going to pick
h.264 first.
But yeah, it's pretty much just
simple, using those APIs.
CanPlayType is the specific
one I'm referring to.
And then having a bit of logic
that we use with user agent
checking to decide if we want
to prefer WebM or h.264.
JEREMY WALKER: Do you see a
lot more devices in the
pipeline that have chips
that support WebM?
GREG SCHECHTER: I actually
don't know much about it.
Some of the people that I talk
to are pretty excited and
they're pretty gung-ho about
pushing WebM and getting it to
be a better experience
on mobile.
But a lot of it I just hear
second-hand, so I'm not sure.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: We actually
work with the WebM team, so
perhaps we should invite
them to GDL and tell
us more about it.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah, that
would be interesting.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: That's
a great idea, Jeremy.
All right, so I know we have a
couple of things we wanted to
cover today.
Jeff wanted to talk about
Stack Overflow.
And we wanted to look to see if
there were any questions.
So why don't we transition
over to Jeff.
And first of all, thank
you very much.
GREG SCHECHTER: My pleasure.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: For telling us
more about your experience
building HTML5 as a web
warrior at YouTube.
And thank you for sharing these
wonderful photos with us.
So now, let's transition over
to Jeff, who is joining us
from New York.
Jeff, tell us more about
Stack Overflow.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Sure.
And I also wanted to thank Greg
because that was super
interesting and really
informative, so thank you.
So, Stack Overflow.
First of all, hopefully a lot
of you out there are already
familiar with Stack Overflow.
This is a very established
technical resource that I use
on a daily basis just to look
up answers to questions.
Not necessarily asking questions
every day, but it's
kind of known as being a really
high quality question
and answer site that has
built-in ways of promoting the
right answer.
If maybe you get six different
answers and one of them
happens to be a lot more
correct, let's say, or a lot
more valuable than
the other ones.
Stack Overflow is really good
about exposing the right
answer to a given question.
So we're big fans.
Within Google's developer
relations group, a lot of
teams have already moved over
to Stack Overflow as the
primary source of providing
answers
to developer questions.
Before Stack Overflow, a lot
of teams, including YouTube
API, had a dedicated Google
group, which had a web
interface and an email-based
interface where people could
ask questions.
And it works great for basic
questions and for working as a
mailing list, and we're still
maintaining a Google group for
announcement only emails that
folks can still subscribe to.
But we really wanted to take
advantage of some of the
community features that
Stack Overflow offers.
And the fact that people have
been asking questions on Stack
Overflow related to YouTube and
the YouTube APIs for years
now, really.
And we haven't been
answering them.
It's kind of hard looking
in a bunch of
different forums at once.
Our focus has been on the Google
group up until now.
But now we're looking forward
to being able to answer
people's questions on
Stack Overflow.
So folks who are organically
finding that site and asking
questions there will suddenly
start getting answers from
Google's developer relations
team, and YouTube API
developer relations
team specifically.
A lot of the questions
previously had been answered
by members of the community.
And that's another great thing
about Stack Overflow.
We're really looking forward to
the fact that there is an
active community of developers
who are experts in all
different aspects.
And hopefully we'll get some
more API questions that are
answered by people other
than my immediate
team on Stack Overflow.
So that should make things a
little bit better or for
everybody, quicker answers
for everybody.
The gist of it is that starting
on October 15, we're
not going to accept any new
posts to our existing Google
group that was set up for
YouTube API questions.
So it's going to go into
archive-only mode, which means
we'll still be able to make
references to old posts that
might have a canonical
answer somewhere.
That's not going to go away.
It's still going to show
up in the Google
search index, obviously.
It's just that we're not going
to let people post any new
questions there.
And we're asking that people
take things that are questions
to Stack Overflow.
But we're also going to be
promoting, and, I guess,
making a little bit more
prominent, our issue tracker
that's been around for probably
five years now, and
using the issue tracker as the
authoritative place to report
bugs with the API, or to put
in feature requests.
Stack Overflow is very
specifically a question and
answer site, and a place to go
for technical questions.
It's not a place to report bugs,
and it's not a place to
request features.
And I think the Stack
Overflow moderators
tend to be a little--
they're very diligent about
closing feature requests and
bugs that get posted there.
So please keep in mind that if
you have a feature request or
you have a bug, use our existing
issue tracker.
We're going to get a lot better
about keeping up to
date on the things that come
into issue tracker.
And it just lets us do things
like assign a specific bug
number that matches up with our
internal bug database with
an existing external bug, just
to have the record keeping a
little bit cleaner than what
we could get in the Google
group when people would
report bugs there.
So that overall migration,
again, is going to take place
on October 15.
Folks don't have to wait until
then to start posting on Stack
Overflow or start filing feature
requests or bugs in
the issue tracker.
You can certainly do that now.
And we're hoping that it leads
to a better overall developer
experience for everybody
out there.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Jeff, What
tag should people use when
they file the Stack Overflow
questions?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah, that's
definitely important.
Stack Overflow gets a very
large number of questions
every day, so we have to be able
to find your question if
we want to answer it.
And the specific tag that we're
asking developers to use
is YouTube-API.
And that's the one we're going
to be looking for.
I know that a lot of people
right now are posting things
that are tagged with just
YouTube without
hyphen API at the end.
Those might get our attention
every once in a while, but
we're going to really going to
be focusing on the ones that
are YouTube-API.
Because those, we know, are
API-related questions, rather
than somebody who's just asking
something about the
YouTube website, for
instance, which we
really can't help with.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Now, as far
as those people that have
gotten addicted to emails from
you, is there still a place
where they can receive them?
JEFFREY POSNICK:
So we have that
announcement only email group.
That's going to keep around.
We'll have links to
all these groups.
Well, we have links to all these
groups in a blog post
that recently went up on
apiblog.youtube.com.
But we'll put it in links,
either this video or our
Google+ page so you know
where to sign up.
We're going to keep around
that email-only announce
group, and that's where we're
going to be pushing out email
notifications about important
changes to the API.
We have a few other channels
where people
can stay up to date.
Obviously, that aforementioned
blog is a great thing to
subscribe to if you want to get
notified whenever we have
a new blog post.
And we have our also
aforementioned Google+ page,
which is
google.com/plusyoutubedev.
And subscribing to that will let
you know when we're having
all these fun YouTube Developer
Live events, as well
as any other important
updates that we want
to push out to folks.
And also--
this might be a nice segue--
one of you mentioned that
people can ask questions of
us, not only via Stack
Overflow, but also via the
Google Moderator interface
that we have for each of
these weekly YouTube
Developer Live sessions.
So we can answer some live
questions during these, or for
more complicated things, we
might just ask folks to find
us on Stack Overflow with all
the debugging details and that
sort of thing.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
Speaking of which, Jeremy,
do we have any
questions in the moderator?
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah, actually,
we have a few.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So Jeff, thank
you for covering the
Stack Overflow migration.
I think we are really looking
forward to being more scalable
and then having some community
participation.
I think one thing that I
personally like about Stack
Overflow is, in addition to good
karma, it also helps you
with reputation, and you can
earn some badges, which is
really cool, since we all play
games, and life wouldn't be
the same without badges.
All right.
Jeremy, over to you.
JEREMY WALKER: Let's
get started.
So the first question is
actually on HTML5.
So they actually want to know
from your perspective, what's
the best resource
to get started?
And then second, what are the
prerequisites they need to
know before they start
messing with HTML5?
GREG SCHECHTER: I've been a
big fan of the Opera Web
Standards Curriculum.
Now this covers web development
in general, and
there is some HTML5
stuff in there.
Once you're getting into the
newer things, the things that
are really awesome, HTML5 Rocks
has a bunch of great
examples and links to more
resources and more detail.
So those are some of the--
those two things.
The Opera Web Standards
Curriculum and HTML5 Rocks are
some of my favorite places
to look at good examples.
After that, you're like having
to read the spec for these
things, and that can get
a little complicated.
JEFFREY POSNICK: I also want
to point out, I really like
the Mozilla developer network
pages, specifically for
providing what seems to me,
at least, the canonical
definition of different
JavaScript objects and the
methods they expose, and code
samples for all those.
It's not specific to HTML5
JavaScript, but if you're
doing anything, I always tend to
click on Mozilla developer
network links when
I have a search.
GREG SCHECHTER: That's one of
the best places to find
documentation for any web
development stuff.
JEREMY WALKER: And what
about prereqs?
What do you think you have
to know before you get
started with that?
GREG SCHECHTER: You have
to know HTML5,
JavaScript, and CSS.
You really don't have to
be too advanced in
it just to get started.
I mean that's--
one of the goals of HTML5 is
to make it simple, so that
anybody on the web can
build this richness.
And so just to get a video
playing, it's as simple as
having a video tag with
a source, and
just a controls attribute.
And so there's really not too
much, but you do need to be
familiar with HTML5, JavaScript,
and CSS.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
So we've got a couple more.
One is, they basically want to
know, if an onProgress event
is coming so that you
can get the--
the refire for progress
and seek.
They currently are pulling
the get player
state to get the progress.
GREG SCHECHTER: That's actually
an interesting one.
I actually got into a discussion
with somebody about
onProgress and other APIs.
I'm currently trying to convince
the team that not
only do we need to have events
like onProgress, but I think
that we need to really enhance
our API to be able to provide
the richest experience
that we can give.
So one of the interesting things
is HTML5 has some new
APIs that deal with just
media in general.
And they do a better job at
providing API than we do.
And I think that for us, in
order to make sure that people
are still able to build great
applications on the web using
YouTube, I think that we need to
have an API that's not only
on par, but even better than
what you get natively.
So it's something that
I'm trying to
convince the team to do.
That one, I don't think, should
be very difficult.
So hopefully, these things will
come, but I'm not quite
sure when we'll be
able to get them.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: In the
meantime, what is the
work-around?
Just set up a timer and
use the iframe API?
GREG SCHECHTER: Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Just pull?
GREG SCHECHTER: It's
just a timer.
250 milliseconds should
be able to--
I believe in our documentation
we say that even
GetCurrentTime is going to be,
at most, out of date by 250
milliseconds.
So you can at least just have
a timer on that, and that
should be the same.
But it's not-- right, it's not
as comfortable to program that
way when you're using an
event-driven environment.
But yeah.
250 milliseconds should
be at least a good
work-around for now.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
JEREMY WALKER: We have another
question from the Netherlands
around HTML5 versus Flash.
So in HTML5, it downloads the
whole video, whereas Flash
only downloads what it needs
to not rebuffer again
until it needs to.
So they basically asked if
you're aware of this.
GREG SCHECHTER: This is
something that we're aware of.
For HTML5, the buffering
is out of our hands.
As the spec currently stands,
it's decided by the browser.
For Flash, it has to do with
our streaming and the
adaptive-ness.
And so we don't buffer as much
because you might switch
qualities quickly and
we don't want to get
all that extra thing.
It's something that's
in discussion.
If you go into the Settings
menu and you change the
format, if it's anything that's
not auto, it should
buffer all the way through.
Otherwise, it only does a little
portion of it and it'll
wait until you've start
playing more.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Let's see, so we have
another one.
Lots of developers need the
classic player plus one
feature, and currently if you
need that, you need to
basically get the whole entire
chromeless player.
And they were--
well, it was more suggestion,
but I guess the question would
be, is there any chance that
we're going to release a
plug-in where you get the bare
bones, and you can add like
one of the features, as opposed
to getting the entire
chromeless player.
GREG SCHECHTER: Sure.
So for some of our features like
annotations and captions,
where we're working on getting
APIs available so you can turn
those things on and off and
get that, for things like
still having our controls and
adding things to it is not
something that we've
really discussed.
But I'll bring it back
to the team and
see what people think.
But it's not something that's
in the pipeline yet.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
And the top question, is Google
YouTube developer
relations hiring?
And, of course, we are.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
I can take that.
Both Google developer relations
and YouTube
developer relations
are hiring.
To learn more, go to
developers.google.com/jobs,
and you will see all the types
of positions that we are
hiring for, and also a little
bit more information about
what we do.
There was one more
question added.
I think it came through from
Israel, about playback rate
control via the API.
So I can take that since I
play around with that.
So the question is whether
there's a way to actually
change the playback rate
using the API.
So if you have been paying
attention with HTML5 player,
you can actually change the
speed at which the video
plays, which is a really cool
feature that a lot of people
don't know about.
But I personally
like it a lot.
Because a lot of times when I'm
watching video on demand,
I prefer to go through it
quickly, especially if it's
some kind of educational
content, like
this one, for example.
With HTML5, actually, we
do have an iframe API.
So if you go to the iframe API
reference, you'll see two
relevant methods.
One is called getPlaybackRate.
And you can actually get the
rate at which the video is
playing today.
You can see a playback rates
at which the playback is
available for given video.
So that's
getAvailablePlaybackRates.
And then, setPlaybackRate
will let you control
the playback rate.
So that is actually already
available for HTML5.
Last time I checked, we didn't
actually support it for Flash.
So nothing is going to blow up
if you invoke these iframe API
operations.
Again, iframe API abstracts the
differences between the
Flash player and the
HTML5 player.
And this is, I suppose, why
you might be having some
issues trying to convince the
team to add new APIs, because
we always have to
look at both.
And we attempt to provide a
consistent user experience for
developers across these
different technologies.
So for the Flash player, if you
look at available playback
rates, you only see one,
and it's going to be a
multiplier of one.
And then if you set it, then
you're going to get back to
where you were, which is
standard playback.
So we don't have that for Flash
yet, but you can play
around with it already
in our HTML5 player.
GREG SCHECHTER: And just to
clarify, although the API is
there and working in the HTML5
player, not all of the
browsers have support for
variable playback speeds.
So this'll work great in Chrome,
but Opera does not
have this feature yet.
So you'll only get--
if you query what available
playback speeds are, you're
always going to get just one.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Hence, you
have nine mobile browsers on
your phone and probably even
more on your desktop.
GREG SCHECHTER: Yep.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
I think we have run out of
questions, and running out of
time as well.
So I would like to thank
you all for watching.
See you next week, same time,
same place, virtually on the
net, or perhaps on the hangout
in the studio.
Jeff, I hope your cough
continues improving.
I've been counting your
coughs every session.
I think this has been the best
one thus far, unless you've
been using mute secretly.
JEFFREY POSNICK: I've
been secretly muted.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Oh no,
that's cheating.
JEFFREY POSNICK: I'm going to
see if I can install a mute
button, maybe, in my bronchial
tubes or something like that.
Just spare everybody in
the office around me.
Either that or get better.
I prefer the latter.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
Take it easy, and thank you
very much for watching.
We'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]